the fabric of America is free a nation
on edge after days of discord physical
confrontations raging flames and no
resolution this is how erratic it's
become
[Applause]
[Music]
you're someone that in Salt Lake City
the man targets protesters with a bow
and arrow in Chicago police officers had
dragged through the streets the trust
has eroded on every side of this battle
a police car drives into a crowd
[Applause]
decades of racial injustice is reached
boiling point not just about George
Floyd it's about everybody it's about
every single black person in this
country who has been systematically
about so this is the overflow of the
things that we've been talking about for
the last what seven years people think
that after civil rights things that
ended and it happened it seems like
civility and stability has been
abandoned from coast to coast I'm sad
and I'm heartbroken
this was I've lived through this before
there's been an apartment for 38 years
and I'm afraid that we'd never be back
in this type of situation we watched the
turmoil unfold on the president's
doorstep nothing like this has happened
outside the White House in recent memory
[Music]
America's president the man who seems to
relish conflict is now surrounded by it
and he's already using it as a political
weapon lamenting the scourge of the
radical left here just a couple of
hundred meters from the White House the
Capitol we go out there to help people
not do that nonsense there are those
pushing for peaceful demonstrations here
a police officer from Michigan gives up
his protection to join the protesters
[Applause]
but two crises are convulsing in America
a pandemic and police violence and there
is no sign of a quick cure for either